[Música]
pasamos a las noticias económicas con
Daniela hablandola Daniela Buen día para
usted Hola buen día buen feliz inicio de
semana pues lo mismo le deseo los que no
están muy contentos son los franceses el
gobierno anunció más medidas para frenar
la inflación Así es Ángela el ministro
de finanzas Bruno lema estuvo de visita
en el supermercados hablando con sus
dirigentes y anunció que llegó a un
acuerdo con las principales cadenas del
país que consiste en que ellos van a
ofrecer a los compradores los precios
más bajos posibles durante un periodo de
tres meses a Costa de una reducción de
los márgenes de los distribuidores más
no de los agricultores o de los
industriales ellos mismos van a ser
quienes escojan los productos y les van
a poner una etiqueta que diga trimestre
antiinflación y en junio lo van a
revisar para ver si pueden extenderlo
Qué tan grave es la situación de los
precios en Francia nos vamos a mirar la
inflación anual en febrero se aceleró
leve y sorpresivamente hasta el 7,2% acá
lo vemos pero en el caso de los
alimentos es de más del 14% y en el caso
de la energía también es del 14%
impulsado como en gran parte del
continente por estas dos rubros está la
inflación en Francia la mala noticia es
que expertos dicen que todavía no ha
alcanzado su pico y que de hecho tiene
cierto margen de seguir subiendo porque
sus cifras estuvieron entre las más
bajas de la zona Euro el año pasado
en otros temas de China fue más Modesto
que antes en sus proyecciones económicas
de este año de eso se ha hablado mucho
el fin de semana Así es el fin de semana
comenzó este asamblea popular China y
pues este país lleva varios años con
dificultades para poder cumplir sus
metas y por eso la de 2023 por lo menos
en lo que tiene que ver con el
crecimiento es mucho más moderada que
antes el gobierno de Jean pingüe será
Quien será ratificado en la cita anual
de esta asamblea popular o el
legislativo chino espera para este año
Un aumento del producto interno bruto
del 5% frente al tímido 3% que creció el
año pasado que el déficit fiscal sea del
3% de este pib también Busca crear 12
millones de nuevos empleos urbanos que
fue lo mismo del año pasado y que su
tasa de desempleo se ubique en un
5,15,5%. El Ejecutivo de She dio dijo
este lunes que va a poder cumplir estas
metas escuchemos
desde principios de año el consumo de
China se ha venido acelerando
hoy se están eliminando gradualmente
algunos factores inciertos que
restringen el consumo Así que con la
rápida liberación del potencial de
consumo se espera que la tasa de
crecimiento de los principales
indicadores se recupere gradualmente en
la primera mitad del año como ha
reaccionado a esto el mercado pues
Ángela china es el mayor consumidor del
mundo en especial en lo que tiene que
ver con materias primas y eso hace que
sea muy importante estas proyecciones
porque cualquier previsión que sea más
moderada va a poner a pensar de un modo
menos optimista a todos los que le
venden esos insumos varios de ellos acá
en América Latina la estrategia de
Beijing Parece ser esta vez Entonces
metas a plantearse metas más
conservadoras para que las pueda cumplir
y no como en años anteriores bueno Y a
propósito de China cómo amanecen los
indicadores este objetivo menos
ambicioso y más realista hizo que los
índices bursátiles asiáticos cerraran
positivos impulsado sobre todo por Japón
que es la tercera Economía del mundo si
nos vamos a Europa los índices superan
al alza con excepción de Londres después
de que el economista jefe del Banco
Central europeo advirtiera que es
posible que las tasas sigan subiendo
inclusive si los precios tienden a bajar
un poco y mi siguiente Pregunta para
usted Daniela Ya cambiando de tema ese
porque el gobierno de Estados Unidos
decidió demandar al gigante exxon móvil
pues la historia es la siguiente Ángela
comienza en enero de 2020 cuando un
empleado negro denunció haber encontrado
una soga de ahorcado en su lugar de
trabajo en el complejo petrolero de
veyton Hush en Luisiana administrado por
Epson móvil en ese momento la compañía
sabía que se habían encontrado otras
tres sogas en el complejo también de
trabajadores negros pero no investigó
las quejas ni tomó medidas para evitar
este acoso esto lo dice la comisión de
igualdad de oportunidades en el empleo
de Estados Unidos en una demanda que
interpuso por vio de la ley federal
después se encontró una quinta soga en
otro complejo pues leer quien es El
Vocero de exxon móvil respondió en un
comunicado que este gigante del petróleo
tiene una política de tolerancia cero de
cualquier forma de acoso o de
discriminación en el lugar de trabajo
por o hacia los empleados o también a
los contratistas o proveedores inclusive
a los clientes y también alentó a los
empleados a denunciar afirmaciones como
esta para investigarlas a fondo sin
embargo después de todo esto Ángel al
gobierno de Estados Unidos considera que
todavía la falta de acción de Epson
móvil ha creado un ambiente de trabajo
racialmente hostil como lo llaman ellos
y vamos a cambiar con una noticia un
poco más agradable Si se quiere y es un
icono del chocolate que va a perder su
tradicional imagen cómo es esta historia
Ángela ha probado los toblerones Pero
por supuesto Quién no los ha probado los
tableros en los aeropuertos bastante si
son bastante populares Pues esta popular
marca comenzó a comercializarse hace 115
años en Suiza y en su logo principal
todos lo sabemos figura el monte suizo
servino que también es conocido como
matterhood pues la multinacional
estadounidense mondeless es la dueña de
esta marca inicialmente Suiza desde 2012
y decidió trasladar parte de su
producción a Eslovaquia para ahorrar
costos en medio de la alta inflación en
este continente Pues por culpa de esta
decisión va a tener que eliminar esa
icónica montaña del empaque ya que las
leyes suizas establecen que para que un
producto pueda presentarse como hecho en
el país y tener por ejemplo esta bandera
roja con blanco muy característica y es
algo que también suele asociarse a
precios más caros pues para que todo
esto pase debe tener un 80% de sus
materias primas provenientes en el
territorio y ese porcentaje aumenta al
100% en el caso de la leche y de sus
derivados Pues el traslado de producción
de toblerone a Eslovaquia concretamente
a una planta de la capital bratislava
fue anunciado en junio del año pasado
después de más de un siglo de
fabricación en Berna ahora el último
dato que le doy el empaque ya no va a
decir fabricado en Suiza sino
establecido en Suiza Cómo se sentirán
las personas a las que uno les trae este
dulce ya no va a ser suizo Pues a mí me
sigue pareciendo rico Pero bueno vamos a
finalizarle con su cifra del día 39,4
millones de turistas que esperan México
para 2023 con un incremento anual del
2,7% frente a 2022 estas proyecciones de
la secretaría de turismo dicen que si
esto se cumple los ingresos provenientes
por este concepto van a superar los 30
mil millones de dólares y van a pasar
los niveles pre pandémicos Daniela
gracias a ustedes nos vemos más tarde
con más noticias económicas así será